Yeah.
Yeah, we'll talk about all that
SAURABH.
Yeah, let's get into the session
and then we'll talk about all
the details.
File says there is one stream
app which works in offline mode
as well.
Uh, can we have?
That is it's stream option in
teams.
I'm not really sure, maybe you
can just drop in an email to
OPS.
Yeah, but what I am aware is you
cannot download these videos.
It is an in app just like you're
say, Netflix, hot star or prime.
Whatever you'll be able to, you
know, if you download it even
without Internet, you will be
able to watch those videos.
But it will not come out of the
app.
Not like you download it as an
MP4, you know share it across
and so on.
That is not possible.
We'll just give it another two
minutes and then we will get
started, yeah.
And for all the folks who are
joining using personal ID,
please don't do that.
And the next session, please
join using your bits email ID
and if you're doing so, it'll
automatically allow you only
when you're using Gmail and
others on, there'll be a pop-up
like admit into the class, and
so on.
Yeah, because this recording
will also be placed in teams.
Yeah.
So inside the same codes,
whenever you come here inside
teams, there will be a folder
called files recordings and that
will be available there.
No, there will not be any
classes on Sunday for your
section.
You will have it on Saturday, so
you have four classes today,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
So then you have a full day
Saturday class and Sundays.
You're free.
Yeah, that is for the first
semester.
And as you progress in your
Mtech, maybe in your second or
third semester, it also depends
on the courses you're you take,
right?
Maybe three courses on a
Saturday?
One course in a Sunday or, you
know, it might so happen based
on your electives that you
choose and so on.
Yep, Python classes are over
right.
What about that?
So all of you heard, did you all
practice Python And are you all
comfortable with it?
Yeah, go to has a question.
How is this different from
regular batch?
What do you mean by regular
batch?
You are the regular batch,
right?
OK, OK.
Yeah.
Cool.
We'll just give it a minute.
And 8:35 let's get started.
If you're not practiced enough,
it's still good time.
You can, you know, get started.
You can practice it.
No, no, not handwritten.
And so on.
I'll talk about everything.
Yeah.
Please hold on for a couple of
minutes.
We will talk about all the, you
know, integrities of the course.
Yeah, everything will first, you
know, spend a good 20-30 minutes
in discussing all this.
Ohh it'll all be covered in my
deck and then we will, you know,
have a look.
Not will, but regular for the
folks who join as a regular
degree.
You mean on campus?
Students right?
It is the exact same course.
Yeah, it is the exact same
handout.
It is the same, you know,
course, and that is why I keep
telling, you know, we'll
students to take it seriously
because the course doesn't know
you.
Yeah, it doesn't know if you are
a 20 year old sitting on campus
or you know all your work
commitments and so on.
It is the exact same textbook.
It is the same exact same course
and exact same evaluative
components like C1C2C3 yeah.
But you are doing all the
classes on one single day, but
they will have it all spread
across.
They have all the time in the
world.
They'll have other, you know,
extracurricular activities and
all that.
But the academic angle to it is
exactly the same.
It's the same handout, same
books and so on.
Cool.
I think it's 8:35, so let's get
started.
So just let me know once the
screen is visible.
Yeah, it should be.
Cool.
So welcome to the first contact
session for data structures and
algorithm design, and uh, today
we will just, you know, get
started with what is this course
all about and we will start
having a look at the first
module, right?
So the agenda for today, we will
have a look at what is this
course all about what is the
course handout, what are the
books, what are the evaluation
components for this course and
how do you make the most out of
this course, right?
It's a six month course, right?
So how to make the best out of
it?
We'll also have a look at the
motivation and synergy for why
should you even learn this
course right?
All of you have enrolled for
Mtech in data science and
engineering.
And why is this subject called
data structures and algorithm
design coming your way?
Right.
We will have a look at that then
we will get started with the
first module where we will have
a look at introduction to
algorithms and also about
analysis of algorithm
efficiency. Right.
We'll try to do that.
Yeah, all of you here.
Yes.
No, that clear what we are
trying to do, we look at all the
nitty gritty S and then we will
move on to the actual codes,
right.
So did all of you also get a
chance to look at the uh post in
canvas?
I hope most of you know me.
Yeah, we met in the Python
course, otherwise I had also
posted and you know canvas,
right.
So we have two sections in this
course for this class, so I'll
be handling Section 1 and I'm
the CEO of this course and we
also have Professor Raghavan who
will be handling the second
section right?
It's exactly the same.
It's the same deck, same
portion, everything is exactly
the same. Cool.
They could not access the
syllabus for section one and
Section 2.
What do you mean by that?
Uh, Manisha, I don't understand.
What do you mean by Section 1,
Section 2?
Anyway, we'll come there.
Yeah, let's finish this first
introductory, you know, 1520
minutes and then, uh, for any of
access issues or anything,
please drop an email to OPS.
Yeah, OPS dot BC at, you know,
the ideas that have been shared.
Cool.
Firstly, what is that textbook?
So the textbook name is
algorithm design, foundations
analysis and Internet examples
by Goodrich and Tamassia.
Yeah, it's a very old book, but
it is still a classic.
Yeah.
So there are several editions of
this book, and you can go with
any of them.
There is an international
edition.
There is an Eastern Economy
edition and so on.
So anything that suits you need,
you can go ahead and buy that as
I also told, I will not be able
to, you know, upload these
books.
This is all strictly, you know,
copyright violation for the
Python book, since I know the
authors, I had taken some
written permissions and I had,
you know, uploaded it.
But for this one I will not be
doing that.
So it is up to you to either buy
a online copy or a actual book
and it doesn't cost much.
It is just, you know, going to
cost you a, you know, 500, six
₹100, yeah.
A reference book?
Yeah, this is called CLS.
How many of you have heard about
this book?
Yeah, it's a very, very famous
book.
Yeah, it is called uh, you know
CRS, the Clr just stands for,
you know, the names of them.
Yeah.
Csat for common you know, Carmen
and so on.
So it is called introduction to
algorithms and it is also, you
know, fondly called as the Bible
of algorithms.
Yeah, aware of question is this
is a really, really good book,
but there's a caveat here that
it is also a very, very lengthy
book.
Yeah, it is very lengthy and it
is having a lot of mathematical
rigor.
Yeah, typically this book cannot
be completed in one semester.
Yeah.
So what I would suggest is first
complete the textbook and then
if you have any you know,
specific topics, go ahead and
look at this book.
They don't right away, you know,
jump with the ambition of
completing this whole, you know,
book and you know, less than six
months.
Yeah, that is not possible.
Of course, in uh, my classes,
I'll be pinpointing you to
certain concepts that go ahead
and refer this particular, you
know, Carmen book for this
concept.
Yeah.
Is it clear for all of you?
Yes, no.
Yeah.
So this is so and both of these
are very, very famous books.
I mean, the moment you start
Googling the name of this book,
you might find you know versions
of it.
So anything that suits you need,
you can either buy the book or
you can have an online copy of
it.
Yeah, but please don't upload
anything on canvas.
Yeah, just use it for your own
reference.
Or you can share it in other
channels.
Don't upload anything on canvas.
Yeah, some of the reference
books just for you to, you know,
computer algorithms by, you
know, Sahani and Raja Sekaran.
So this is more of a Indianized
version.
Yeah.
And there is also this book
called data structures and
Algorithms in Python.
Yeah.
If you see the authors here,
it's again the same Goodrich
Tamassia and so on.
But what this book is all about
is this is more of a supplement
to the actual textbook.
Yeah.
So if you remember, this is the
textbook and the same authors,
along with another Co author,
have written another book where
Most Concepts have been
implemented in Python, right?
Yeah.
Do you get this point?
And there's also this slack
that, you know, illegal to sell
in USA and so on.
So there are several editions of
this, so this also you can go
ahead and buy.
So this is basically a book
completely written on Python,
just to supplement the other
textbook, right?
If I told you, you know, want
this, you can also go ahead with
this.
Yeah.
For this course we will be using
just Python.
Yeah, that is the whole point.
Why we learned Python in the 1st
place before the 1st semester?
Yeah.
And this is not it.
So there are several books
available in the market, because
this is a very, very typical,
you know, fundamental
theoretical computer science.
We have plenty of textbooks
available for this, like your
friends were asking in the chat
right now, and a lot of other
books are there.
I mean, is a good friend of mine
from IIT Bombay.
There's a lot of other books,
even I've heard, you know, CBC
and other books.
They also introduce, you know,
these courses in school.
Yeah, of course.
At a very, you know, fundamental
level, but there are several
books available.
Several, you know, Internet
resources, so you can go with
any of them that you like,
right?
But the one that is the main one
is this textbook, right?
So 90 to 95% of this course, the
syllabus will be already
available in this book.
And for those rest of the
potions, I will pinpoint you.
I'll tell you that you know, you
know what these concepts are not
there in your textbook.
So refer to my slides or refer
to this book, I'll pinpoint you
to that.
Yeah, otherwise you can just
rely on this textbook.
Yeah.
Is that clear?
All of you?
Yes.
No, maybe.
OK, so some ground rules?
Yeah.
So this is the same thing as
your Python code, so please try
to be regular.
Yeah.
So you have just 16 sessions and
we have two hours each plus some
webinars.
Please try to be as regular as
possible, although there is no
attendance.
Try to come to the classes be
regular and also you know try to
uh be In Sync even if you missed
some classes.
Watch the videos and so on.
Yeah.
So again ohh I keep repeating
that so be mentally present
right?
So observe.
Listen, what is happening and in
my class I keep, you know,
answering questions or you know,
I keep asking you questions.
So you know, please be alert and
you have the complete physical
comfort.
You are at your home, so try to
be no mentally present.
Keep your questions for the
Q&A section.
I'll keep you know, giving you
breaks.
You can also, you know, ask
there or in between.
Also, I'll keep you know looking
at the chat and use the
discussion forum of canvas
effectively, so this discussion
forum is our section.
Yeah, this is very, very
important guys.
I will also show you in a minute
once you open canvas, there will
be 2 sections now, right?
And you will go into our section
and there there will be a
discussion forum and that is
where you will ask all your
doubts and so on.
Right.
I'll show you in a minute.
So all the exercises regularly.
Yeah.
Every slide deck.
Yeah, trust me, every slide deck
will have the last deck as
certain questions or exercises.
Yeah.
These are all ungraded excises,
just for you to practice.
Please try to do that.
Yeah.
Don't keep it for long.
Try to do that, yeah.
Will the extra mile so I have
been telling this even in your
Python course, right?
So you enroll for this course.
That doesn't mean the job is
over, right?
The job just starts right?
So all of you are going to put
in effort that is like, you
know, 365 one to the power 365
is just one.
But if you just raise that by a
little extra right, the extra
effort that you put in that is
going to give you tremendous
results, right?
So so try to go that extra mile.
Just don't ask questions like
you know.
I mean, is your slide enough?
Is the textbook enough?
And so on.
Try to go the extra mile.
Complete your slides.
Complete your books and try to,
you know, learn extra.
You can always, you know,
discuss in the discussion forum
and, you know, make the best out
of this course.
Yeah, that being said, we will
first, you know, go to the
handout.
We'll have a look at that.
We'll also have a look at the
canvas and so on, and then we'll
come back to the slides.
Yeah.
Meanwhile, let me just answer a
couple of questions.
Santosh asked why Bits will not
provide any PDF as well.
Yes, it will not provide because
it is all copyright correct.
So we need to always respect the
authors, and there is so much of
effort involved in it, right?
So for a couple of authors whom
we know individually, we write
it as a, you know, but a mission
and agreement and tell that, you
know, we are going to share
your, you know, digital copy of
the book, free to all students.
And if they are willing, if
they're very magnanimous, they
might be like, yeah, fine.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Otherwise, it's a very big, huge
loss, right?
I mean, why would they do that?
Right.
So as bits we will not do that,
but there are a lot of other
legal ways, right where you can,
you know, use your bits ID.
There are some, you know,
platforms who give discounts and
so on, and you can actually buy
those books, right?
So for all of you who are not
able to access canvas.
So please write to them.
There is an OPS ID right?
Even in the Python codes I had
given you, so I will also update
it in canvas.
You can write to them about the
access right?
So what about the solutions to
upgrade excises?
How do we know if we are right
or yeah, I'll talk about that.
Yeah.
So firstly, let's have a look at
the course handout.
Yeah, just let me know once the
PDF document is visible, yeah.
Cool.
So First things first, this is
DSD.
This is called, you know, data
structures and algorithm design,
and the course number is DSECLZG
519, yeah.
Credit units is 5.
Yeah.
And you also have the course
author, FEBIN, ma'am.
And I have done some minor
edits.
Yeah, not much to the course,
but I have just done, you know,
a couple of Boeing concepts here
and there.
Yeah, that is what I have done.
Yeah, someone has already sent
that ID.
Yeah. Perfect.
Yeah, you will get response from
there.
Yeah, the OPS team was, you
know, loaded with a lot of work,
but they will clear all the, you
know, pending emails by, you
know, weekend.
Yeah, by the next class you will
have all those sorted, yeah.
Well, So what does this mean?
What do you mean by credit unit
of five?
Yeah, anyone knows this?
Yeah.
Do you have any, you know, idea
about credits?
No, not 5 modules.
It it simply means a higher
credit course means a higher
impact.
Yeah, this will in the grading
and so on it will be you know
more of a higher impact as well
as similar is right.
This exactly translate to the
effort needed.
Yeah, the hours that you need to
spend for a course that is given
by the credit units, right?
So approximately so one credit
unit translates to around 30
hours, right?
If it is, say, five credit
units, you can multiply that
right?
So around 1:50, you know, units
and so on and it is not very
difficult, right around 3032
hours we are going to spend in
classes and again another good 8
to 10 hours you will spend it in
webinars and then uh in your
assignments, right in both your
assignments, you will be
spending a good you know 1020
days and put together all that
you know makes it to about you
know, hundred 150 hours you can
have a look at these offline,
uh, I still see a lot of people
joining with guest, yeah.
But every semester there will be
one credit with uh.
Yeah, it might be, yeah.
There are some semesters which
might not be.
Course objectives.
You can have a look at it here.
Learning objectives.
All of them are there, right?
The whole content structure,
right?
So for this course we have a 5
modules or six modules rather
yeah, and this is just the
module right?
So you will mostly go ahead and
have a look at this session
plan, right?
So the session plan is more
detailed, right?
It talks about what are we going
to do in every session?
Yeah.
Is it clear?
Yeah.
So if you see here, this is the
first class.
This is second class.
This is the 6th class and so on.
We'll have a very detailed, you
know, and then we are going for
mid semester and then you know
for all the 16 sessions you will
have, you know your concepts
listed.
Yeah, yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys all of you.
And there's also this mention
of, you know which textbook,
which section T1 means our
textbook right.
And somewhere, if you find R, it
means you're reference books,
right?
And also the evaluation.
So there are three components.
That is, uh EC1EC2EC3.
Yeah, EC one has two assignments
and two quizzes, right?
And it will be informed in
canvas and I have a habit of
announcing all this very early.
Yeah, early meaning I'll do that
sometime today.
Yeah.
So today itself or tomorrow you
can find an announcement where I
will list all these dates.
Yeah, list all the dates.
Usually the first assignment
will happen before the mid
semester and the first quiz will
happen before the mid semester,
right and 2nd assignment and 2nd
quiz will happen after the mid
semester.
Yeah.
Is that clear?
Set the reference to 15.3 means
textbook one chapter #5 two
Section 5 exactly.
That's right, 5.3 means the
section 5.3 which is Chapter 5
and the third sub topic or
something, yeah.
Yeah, we'll talk about all this.
Yeah, just give me a minute.
So you see one is about 30% or
in our course let's not confuse
all that.
We will just go with mugs.
Yeah, this translates to 30
marks.
So your first assignment will be
for 12 marks, second assignment
will be for 13 Marks and quiz
will be for five marks, right?
That sums it to 30 marks for
assignments.
You will be doing it in groups.
Yeah, the groups will be created
in a couple of weeks.
Just hold down.
That will be done and you'll be
working in groups and then you
will just submit one submission
as a group, whereas for quiz
you'll do it individually and
all of these will happen on
canvas.
And as I told, first assignment
will happen before mid semester.
First quiz will happen before
mid semester and 2nd assignment
and 2nd quiz will happen after
mid semester.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys?
And then you'll have your
midterm exam and your final exam
right midterm exam is again for
30 marks, and final exam is 440
marks.
And again, we have gone back to
the traditional mode.
Yeah.
So the midterm exam will be
closed book exams and
comprehensive exam or your final
exam will be open book exams.
Yeah, you will again get a lot
of, you know, information about
what is allowed and so on in a
separate email.
But just to give you a glimpse,
you'll be able to take the
textbooks.
You will be able to take your
own handwritten notes.
You will be able to take the
slides that I provide and any
other materials that I provide
right books, meaning any
official book should be fine.
Yeah, not just that textbooks.
Any book that you feel you will
be able to take it to the exam
and remember this is an open
book exam.
It is not an open Internet exam.
Yeah.
So you will not be able to use
the Internet while writing the
exam.
Yeah.
Print out of slides are allowed,
yeah.
Yeah.
Couple there will be an option.
I'm not really sure about all
that.
You will get communication from
the OPS teams on that. Yeah.
So there are a lot of changes
kicking in from this semester.
So, uh, you can wait for those,
yeah.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you?
Evaluation scheme.
Any doubts?
No soft copy.
Also, I don't feel it is
possible if you are going to
write it in a center, right?
If you're going to, you know, a
center allotted from bits.
If you're going to go and write
your exam there, then of course
you cannot carry these in your,
you know, pen drive or email,
right?
So if you are using that mode,
then maybe you're not, so you'll
have to take a print out and you
know, carry it and print out of
slides alone, right?
Not the textbook.
Yeah, it is.
Again, directly illegal offense.
Yeah, someone who notices can
even you know, file a copyright
case that you know you have
printed.
The whole textbook?
Yeah, please don't do that.
Handwritten notes can be print
out and you know, maybe you
know, spiral bind it and you can
also, you know, take a print out
of these slides.
So all my slides are open
source.
You can print them, but not the
book.
Yeah.
Yeah, they'll be just two
quizzes, one before mid SIM, one
after modsim and we will take
the best out of two for
assignment.
It is mandatory that you do both
of them and we will just add
them, right?
This is 12 marks.
This is 13 marks.
It is addition, yeah, 12 + 3.
But As for quiz, both the
quizzes will be for FIFA marks.
We will take the best score out
of it in one you have got 3.5 in
one.
You have got five.
We'll take the score five.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you, this is about
your, you know, evaluation and
you know your exams.
Apart from this, what else is
pending?
You have your baby nurse, so
these webinars will happen on
weekdays.
Yeah, you would have already got
a schedule that will happen on
Tuesdays or Thursdays for our
course, and that will be taken
by the teaching assistants.
Yeah, I'll not be taking those.
The teaching assistants will be
taking and those are some
concepts which is not directly
there in the course.
Yeah.
So directly in this handout you
will not find them, but they're
still important.
They are surrounding the course.
Some practical applications?
Or maybe they'll solve, you
know, a couple of questions that
is important from the exam point
of view, right.
Such things they do.
Yeah.
For that also recordings will be
there and you will be able to
watch them.
Yeah, you will get the schedule
for the webinars.
Yeah, they are just 4 webinars
for a course.
Yeah.
For this course the whole
semester, you'll have just four.
Yeah.
So for that also you can just
watch the recordings.
Cool.
Anything else guys?
Any doubts on this course
handout?
Yeah, we don't have a lab for
this course.
So what?
It's very good question.
So what we will do is after
every session I will be
uploading some Python notebooks.
Yeah.
And those Python notebooks are
considered as your lap.
You can just play around with
the notebook.
You can, you know, try to
execute it.
You can manipulate it.
Try to execute it and so on and
that will be your lab.
There is no official lab.
There is no lab exam.
There is nothing you know of
that sort, yeah.
Well, let me just now go to
canvas for example related
questions.
Will there be?
Yeah, there will be a mock exam
and for our course I'll be
uploading a sample paper exactly
one week before the exam, or 10
days before the exam.
And just for you to get
accustomed to the online
platform and so on, there will
be some mock exams, yeah.
Are you able to see the browser
now?
All of you.
These are course canvas page.
If you have not got the access
to it, you will get it sometime
soon.
Don't worry about it in less
than you know 2-3 days.
All this will be sorted, but
most of you have already got.
Yeah, this is the same canvas we
have learned about all this long
back.
Yeah, alright.
You have the lead inspector.
All the names and so on.
And this is where you can
download this course handout.
Yeah, someone was asking about,
you know, how do I get that
syllabus sheet?
Right, so this handout for every
core you will have it.
And for this course you will be
able to write away come to the
course page when you click on
this it will get downloaded
announcements.
I have put a couple of
announcements for you.
Yeah, you can go ahead and read
it.
And then there is this
discussion, which is general.
Yeah, this is common to both the
sections students, right?
Yes. No.
Yeah, of course.
Send out is just to download it
and I'll come to the section.
Yeah, the section for a few
people.
Maybe it is not still accessible
and you know the back end team
is working on it.
So in this discussion you will
try to post questions which are
very generic to both the
sections.
Maybe things like you know your
exam timetable or exam portions
or you have some general no
query queries about the codes
you can ask here.
Modules you can ignore.
There'll be nothing here.
Assignments.
This is where you are.
You know assignments will
happen.
Currently nothing is published.
These are all just placeholders,
nothing is there once it is
published, you will be able to
see quizzes.
Also will happen in this
platform.
Yeah.
So now coming to our own
section, right.
So the moment you come to
canvas, these are all some
generic stuff, but always you
will then come to our section.
Yeah, we will click on section
one that will take you to
another page like this and I
understand for a lot of people
this is still not working, but
that will be fixed.
Yeah, that will be fixed within
another day or so.
And this is where we have our
section specific things. Yeah.
What do you mean by section
specific things?
No, those are not published, you
know, Kishan, don't worry about
all that.
It will be deleted.
You will have only two
assignments, 2 quizzes for this
course.
Yeah, please go with that.
Yeah, those are just
placeholders.
When we create a page in canvas,
it comes by default and those
are not even scheduled.
It is just a placeholder with
that name.
Nothing is there inside that.
Yeah.
So announcements, for example, I
want to say cancel a class.
Yeah, cancel a class, meaning it
is only for our section, right?
It is not for the whole, you
know, dsat course, right?
Maybe Professor Raven is taking
a class.
I'm only you know, on, you know,
I'm taking a all for something.
Say on that day I'll post an
announcement inside the Section
1, meaning all the announcements
that I make here are only for
your section.
Yeah, not for the other
sections.
So don't you know, propagate
information on WhatsApp and
other mediums that, you know, we
don't have a class and so on?
Because whatever I post in this
section announcement is only for
you, not for the other section.
Yeah, if it is common, I would
have posted in the bigger
announcement section itself,
which is something here right in
this page announcement.
If I do that is for everyone.
But if I come to Section 1 and
then post something, it is only
for you and then pages.
Yeah, I have a habit where for
every class I will create a page
here called lecture 1, lecture
2, lecture 3 and so on.
And inside that I will go ahead
and I will put what we learned
that day.
I'll also link the presentation
that way using the class you can
go to discussions and this is
where you will go ahead and the
file section.
Of course you can see all the
files here and the discussion
forum.
This is where you can chit chat
about your doubts queries and
also about the solutions, right?
So can we access Professor again
class also, no, you cannot
access.
Yeah.
So it is for example, if you
imagine a real classroom, right?
Will you be able to go sit in
both the classroom right at,
say, 9:00 AM?
You'll be present only in one
class.
You cannot go sit in both the
class, right?
But rest assured, I will
guarantee you that it is exact
same content that will be
taught.
Yeah.
So I know him for decades.
It is exactly the same course.
It is exactly the same, you
know, topic that will be
covered.
Yeah, don't worry about that.
There is nothing like, you know
there is extra there extra here
and so on.
It's exactly the same.
Yeah.
And in discussions, yeah, this
is very important.
Again.
Yeah.
Uh, from where I can see the
webinar I will post that.
Yeah, I'll post that.
Don't worry about it, I'll post
about webinars as well as all
your exam dates.
I'll post it in announcement.
Yeah, I'll do that today itself.
Yeah, can sample paper questions
where initially so that.
No, that will that will not be
the you know way because that
gives the wrong notion.
So don't worry about all those
exams and so on.
Just enjoy the course and the
exam matters.
We will look at it later.
Yeah, definitely.
I'll upload some sample papers
and so on, but I will do that
just you know when the time
comes, let's cross the bridge.
When it comes, it's not a, you
know, ideal case that you know
we we prepare just for the exam
sake.
Yeah, the course video will be
available in teams.
Yeah, teams is only for live
classes and recordings, and for
everything else, this is your
platform where you will find
your slides, materials, quizzes,
assignments, everything.
Yeah.
So similar and others were
asking uh, how do I know if the
answers are right?
Uh.
Every class you're telling
you're going to give questions.
How do I know if I'm right?
So as I told every slide deck,
every class my last slides will
have some questions pertaining
to that class, right?
If you have attended those two
hours class, if you have been
attentive, you'll be able to
solve them.
Go ahead and try those.
Those are all ungraded.
That is just for you.
And once you solve it, try to
put your answers in this
discussion.
Very important again, this is
for section one.
Yeah.
Inside our section one, you will
go ahead and post that question.
Uh, I mean, you tell that I've
attempted these answers and
you'll just upload your
solutions and these are all
just, you know, uh, free text.
You can type it or you can
upload a document.
Whatever you like, you'll be
able to do and then what will
happen is your whole batch will
vouch for it.
Yeah, they will also solve it
and they will see if the answers
are matching.
If your answers are right, the
teaching assistants will have an
I they'll give you feedback on,
you know.
Have you done it correctly or
not?
And I will also occasionally
pitch in, but officially I will
not be giving any solutions for
all those exercises.
Yeah, they're not a lot of
exercises.
Also, every slide will have just
two questions or three
questions.
So officially I'll not release
any key because they are
ungraded.
It is up to you to just discuss
here and you know, see if we're
all on the right direction or
not.
Yeah.
Is that clear, guys?
All of you?
Yes.
No.
Maybe you'll discuss inside our
sections discussion, right?
If you have any doubts also
we'll put here and so on and
either the TA or your own batch
MITS, or I will answer them.
Yeah.
Is this clear canvas all of you?
And again, if you come back to
the course home page and this is
where I'll also upload the lab
sheets, you see a line here
after this line, I'll add a
section where you'll be able to
see the lab programs lab
program, meaning it is just, you
know, Python notebook pertaining
to each concept that we learn.
Let's say we're learning about
stack.
I'll upload sheet we learn about
say queue.
I upload a sheet so you can just
play around with it.
Yeah, if you miss a lecture,
we'll be able to access the
recorded lectures.
Yes, it'll be on teams.
That is what I again and again
repeat.
You are live classes and
recordings will happen in MS
Teams.
Yeah, you'll have to go into
your same course in MS Teams.
Inside file section there will
be recording folder.
You will have the videos only
that everything else, right from
quizzes, assignments,
discussions, slides, all of
those.
You will be able to have in your
canvas which is this portal that
I'm currently you know, sharing.
Yeah, the the recordings will be
available till you graduate,
yeah.
They're open book and close book
exam paper will be designed by
you only, right?
This means what we learn in the
class and slides.
Will there be enough?
No, it will not be enough.
Yeah.
So I'm I'm very brutally honest
on these topics.
Yeah.
So you're doing a masters
course.
Of course, from bits so badly
studying the slides will get you
there.
I mean, maybe you will clear the
course that is the guarantee
that you might get if you attend
all the 16 classes.
If you have, you know, studied
them.
If you have prepared the slides,
you will clear the codes.
But if you want to really
farewell and get a good hang of
the course, you'll have to go
the extra mile.
You'll go through the, you know,
books.
You'll go through extra, you
know, tutorials, maybe the
reference books.
You'll practice questions
online, right the moment you
type about data structures
algorithm.
There are plenty of, you know,
things floating online.
You will go that extra mile.
Yeah.
Is it clear, guys?
All of you?
Yes.
No.
Maybe.
And it's even an open book exam,
right?
So you have all the materials
and then if there is a question
like you know what is this, what
is that then it doesn't make
sense.
Yeah, we're not, you know,
kindergarten kids.
We're doing masters scores.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's no pass percentage
is 1.
Yeah, it it all depends on the
curve and so on.
So let's not get too much into
all that, but so far are you all
clear with what is this course
about the course handout?
The textbooks for it and also
the canvas page are these things
clear for all of you and the
assessment component 2
assignments?
Both are mandatory 2 quizzes.
With this, you know best of the
two right.
And finally, you also have your
mid semester and final exams.
Textbooks was not cleared.
Why is it not clear Santhosh?
It is also there in this slide.
This is your textbook.
This is the only textbook and
this is the reference book.
Yeah.
So for no subjects, we will be
uploading the books.
The books is on you.
It is up to you to either buy a
physical copy or a digital copy.
Yeah, it is up to you.
Yeah.
Is this clear all of you?
Well, if that is the case, then
let's get started, yeah.
But firstly, what is the
motivation for, you know,
learning this course?
Yeah.
So why should we even learn this
DSD course?
So most of you have you enrolled
for this program, aspiring to be
a data scientist or in the LED
areas or are you already in this
field and you know you want to
appeal yourself?
Is that the case or why is it
that you have enrolled for this
Mtech DC?
Yeah.
Guess how it it is a little
complex.
It is not just percentage and so
on.
We we, you know, get all the
scores out of 100 and do a you
know.
Graph and then try to.
You know great people.
So yeah, it is called relative
grading.
You can read about it online.
Yeah.
Yeah, to upskill yourself.
And so on, right in the in the
field of data science and so on.
There's good and even in such a
role, you would be definitely
creating some solutions which
has code.
Yeah.
So will you be able to do the
whole of data science, data
science, engineering.
Uh, without writing any code?
Is that possible?
There's a lot of no code and all
that you know floating around,
but there is some amount of code
or problem solving that is still
needed.
Yeah.
So this whole you know, field
also has some amount of problem
solving involved.
And when you want to code or
when you want to have some, you
know systematic problem solving
in your mindset, you should have
a very strong understanding of
data structures and algorithms,
right?
And didn't structures and
algorithms knowledge gives us
the ability to improve our
solution to the problem and the
ability to write much better and
efficient code?
Yeah, it will be able to help us
there.
And most importantly, it helps
to build problem solving
mindset.
Yeah, this learning, data
structures and algorithms can be
a major learning curve for any
computer science or data science
student.
That is the whole point why we
are going to have this course in
your next semesters.
You'll be learning a lot of
advanced courses like say, ML,
AI, deep learning, reinforcement
learning, whatnot.
In all that, inevitably, you are
learning some techniques and you
know algorithms.
Do you agree to that? Yeah.
Yes.
No.
Inevitably, machine learning.
What is machine learning?
Yeah.
So let's not talk jargons.
Yeah.
In depth, what is machine
learning?
It is a couple of techniques
inside that.
What is the technique?
Yeah, that technique is again
some algorithm, right?
Maybe you are doing some
clustering.
Your clustering a group of
people or you are, say
classifying something, let's say
a fake news or, you know, real
news, right?
You're doing all that.
It is at the end of the day and
algorithm right?
If it is an algorithm, then you
need to know this course.
You need to know how to write an
algorithm.
What are the different
strategies to write an algorithm
and you know what are the
different data structures
underlying them right?
That is why it makes sense to
learn this course, yeah.
So how many of you have done
this course formally?
Yeah.
Can you just raise your hands
or, you know, put it in the
chat?
When you gonna say yes plus one
and so on.
Most people have started ML
because they didn't want to
become SD.
OK.
Yeah, it's also a good point.
A lot of you know, newbies have
a tough time learning this
course.
Yeah, cool. I think.
A couple of you who have done
computer science engineering
might have definitely, you know,
learned some concepts of this.
Yeah, might be long back, but
that's fine.
Yeah, as I told, we will start
from scratch.
Yeah.
So what we will do now is maybe
for the next couple of minutes,
we will try to go about learning
very fundamentals and about what
we are going to learn in this
course.
Yeah.
Then we will actually learn it.
Yeah.
Will the course language be
dependent or independent as
implementing a?
Yeah, very important question.
Yeah.
So I will answer that right
away.
So in this course, the whole
course in my classes I will not
be teaching anything about
Python, Java or anything.
We will learn data structures
and algorithm design in a very
general setting.
Yeah, we will write something
called as a pseudo code.
We will also learn about that
today.
We will learn about it.
Don't worry, we will not write
any Python code in your quizzes
in your mid semester exam and in
your final exam you will not be
asked to write any program.
You will not be asked to write
Python program.
Will not be asked to write Java
program and so on, right?
The only two places where your
Python programming comes into
picture is your assignment, then
lab right lab, meaning I will
just upload those sheets just
for you to practice.
So you will have to be
proficient in Python to just run
each cell you know.
Try to change it.
Try to see you know how the
output is changing and so on.
And of course, both the
assignments you will be solving
it using Python, right?
That is where Python comes in,
but apart from that, in my class
as well as you know, in the
exams you are not expected to
write any Python programs or any
program for that matter.
Yeah, if you write a program as
you know, a solution, it will
just not be evaluated.
The question itself will very
clearly tell you what is
expected.
Yeah.
Is it clear, guys?
All of you?
Yeah, the Python programming
comes into picture only for your
assignments, not for others.
Yeah.
Cool.
So what is a program?
Yeah.
And before that, what is an
algorithm?
Do you have any uh programs a
set of instructions given to
machine for performing a task?
Yeah, very good.
Yeah.
And what is an algorithm then?
An algorithm is a step by step
procedure for solving a problem
in a finite amount of time.
Yeah.
And then I suppose the
systematic way of organizing and
accessing data.
So if you see this algorithm, it
talks about a step by step proof
feature.
What solving a problem?
Yeah, it cannot solve all the
problems in the world.
Yeah, it cannot solve your
problems for one definite
problem.
We are going to write a step by
step procedure to solve it and
it is going to take a finite
amount of time, right?
And we have a lot of data
involved inside our programs,
right?
We have some variables you need
to store.
Some you know data and that is
where you are processing.
How do I store that effectively?
Right.
You at this point in the data
sense world.
It is even more common, right?
You have tons of data and you'll
be doing a lot of work in that.
How do you store it?
Should it store it in an array
or a linked list or a tree or a
graph or a hash map or a B tree
or AVL tree or a KD tree?
There are a lot of data
structures.
Each of them have their own way
of storing things they own way
of accessing, removal and so on.
So data structures is all about
how do you systematically store
and organize data so that you
can use it efficiently, right?
So algorithms and data
structures put together makes up
your program.
Yeah.
So any program that you take if
you closely inspect it, you'll
be able to see that it uses some
data structures.
It also follows a step by step
process to solve a problem
right?
And algorithm is defined as a
finite sequence of unambiguous
instructions follow to
accomplish a given task.
So whenever you come across
these definitions, more of a
textbook way of definitions try
to break it down right.
It is a finite sequence.
OK.
Well, and good it is.
Step One, Step 2, step three.
It is finite.
It is very unambiguous.
It should be very, very clear
instructions.
Yeah, it cannot be vague, right?
You know, perform this that is a
very vague statement.
Perform what right should be
very specific to accomplish a
given task only that given task
it can do, right?
For example, if you see here
there's a algorithm and you give
a specification of input that is
going to translate it into a
specification of output.
Algorithm describes actions on
the input instance, right?
So it works on the input and it
is going to produce output.
And the beauty of algorithms is
that infinitely many correct
algorithm for the same problem
exists.
Yeah.
For example, if I ask you to do
sorting.
Yeah, and it may do it in one
way.
Yeah.
Whereas AAKASH may do it in
another way, right?
Yes.
No, all of you for sorting the
problem is the same.
I give you a list of numbers or
you know elements, whatever and
you want to sort them in either
ascending or descending.
There are tons of algorithms and
all of them are correct.
You have bubble sort selection
sort, insertion sort, merge
sort, quicksort, radix sort,
bucket, sort, counting sort,
whatnot, heap sort.
All of them are going to do
sorting only and all of them are
correct, right?
Similar to that, for every
problem there are infinitely
correct algorithms to do the
same thing.
Yeah.
So even in your exams, if you
get a problem, there is not a,
you know single way to solve
that.
Yeah.
Nitish Mitglied in one way.
Yeah, Brenda will solute in
another way.
And both of them might work.
Yeah, I cannot tell that.
You know, this is the only way
and that is the whole beauty of
algorithms.
Yeah, an infinite number of
input instances satisfying the
specification is also possible
for the same sorting example.
I can give one to five numbers
or I can give 10,000 numbers any
you know type of numbers I'll be
able to give, right.
Any combination of input as
possible, so infinitely correct
number of inputs are also
possible, right?
With a very crude example,
right.
For example, orange is your
input, you write an algorithm to
make a juice right.
You'll be able to just tell step
by step P lit.
Wash it.
Add this much of sugar and whip
it for these many minutes.
And so on.
That forms your algorithm.
Yeah, but it would be efficient
to solve exactly.
We will come to that.
There is where the whole you
know, of course, becomes
interesting.
Then all of them are correctly
solving the problem.
Then who's better, right?
We will come there, but for now
is this clear, guys, all of you,
what is an algorithm?
What is the data structure and
what is you know an algorithm
doing yes no, just early
morning.
Yeah, I don't see most of you
replying.
It only odd people.
Yeah.
What's going on?
And what are some properties of
an algorithm?
Yeah, this is also important.
Yeah.
What are the different
properties of it?
Input.
Each algorithm should have zero
or more inputs.
Yeah.
Why is it 0?
Because some programs or
algorithms might implicitly
assume some inputs, yeah, it
will already have input within
it.
It will not ask from the user,
right?
In those cases, it might not
have any explicit inputs.
Output.
The algorithm should produce
correct results.
At least one output has to be
produced, right?
We're not doing just for fun,
right?
Each algorithm is going to do
something, so at least one
output.
It should definitely generate,
otherwise there's no point
right?
Which is doing something.
It doesn't produce anything.
Then why are we even doing it
right?
It should definitely produce one
output at least, which should be
correct.
Definitiveness each instruction
should be clear and unambiguous.
Very clear instructions.
The instructions should be
simple and should transform the
given input to desired output.
It should be effective and it
should be finite, meaning the
algorithm must terminate after a
finite sequence of instructions,
right?
Let's take this example of, you
know, making a tea.
So put that bag in a curve.
We'll the kettle with water,
boil the water in.
Kettle pour some you know, boil
milk, sugar and so on and you're
able to 2:30 and in this
algorithm do you feel this is a
very good algorithm or is there
any problems with this?
Yeah.
Yes, think about those
attributes that we learned.
AAKASH Reserve, Zimbra and
others.
Is this an effective algorithm
or does it have some problems?
Yeah, very good amount of water.
It is not given.
Yeah, sugar.
I don't know.
I mean should I put 1KG or 1
gram?
I don't know.
Yeah, add milk.
How much to add right?
Some water, right?
What is some?
Yeah, we did some ML or liters
or that is not given right.
This is definitely an algorithm.
It is step by step process to
make tea, but it is not very
effective.
It is lacking a lot of steps
like you know it is not
definitive.
It is not effective.
It is having ambiguous
instructions and so on, right?
Will you be writing these type
of algorithms here?
You should not be writing these
type of algorithms.
Yeah, it should be very, very
clear and very, you know,
precise, unambiguous
instructions.
And also if you observe here
some steps like 5 and six can be
interchanged right?
So for example, some people
might prefer to add sugar 1st
and then milk on it, or some
people might do milk 1st and
sugared and both are correct.
Some steps of an algorithm can
be interchanged, but some steps
like three and eight cannot be
interchanged right?
Three is boiling and eight is
drinking.
You cannot drink before boiling
it.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys?
So what is this crux?
Whenever we write algorithms, it
may not be exactly the same for
two people.
Yeah, there are some small nitty
gritties which can be
interchanged.
It doesn't matter, but some
major aspects cannot be
interchanged, yeah.
Because of program development.
So this is program development,
not your, you know, software
development software development
of course is different.
It is called SDLC, right?
You go about gathering
requirement.
You design it, you develop it,
you test it, and all those, you
know, things are possible.
Yeah, but here we are talking
about program development.
If a problem is given to you,
how do you go about solving it?
Yeah, firstly understand the
problem.
Ascertain the capabilities of
computational device right.
For example, at the end of the
day, where is your solution
going to run?
Is it going to run on a
computer?
Is it going to run on a washing
machine?
Is it going to run on a rocket?
Is it going to run in a watch?
We don't know, right?
So we should ascertain those
capabilities.
Where is it that it is going to
run?
You will also try to determine
what data structure to use.
What algorithm to use and so on
and then you will design the
algorithm and then you will
prove the algorithms correctness
that you know what this
algorithm works for this problem
whatever I have designed, this
algorithm is going to do the
right thing and then analyze the
algorithm and tell about is it
good or bad or how is it
performing and then implement
the algorithm in any language of
your choice. Right?
So in this course we are not
going to talk about the first
block.
Understanding your problem, you
all are already professionals.
You might be doing this in your
office.
You know day-to-day when a
problem is given, you will be
able to understand what the
problem is, right?
And the second part this we will
learn in this course.
The third thing which is
designing an algorithm we will
learn in this course, proving
the algorithm's correctness.
You can do it in a lot of ways.
You can use mathematical
induction.
You can, you know, he was
mathematical techniques or you
can use some, you know test
cases right.
You can take, you know, a couple
of test cases, edge cases and so
on and try to tell that for all
these inputs my algorithm works
right and analysis of algorithm
we will again look at this in
this course and implementing the
algorithm.
We will not do it in the class.
This is what you will do in your
assignment, right?
You will first design all this
and you will also try to come up
with a Python program for that.
Yes, no hall of you clear with
this.
Put the last box is not even
important.
Yeah, of course it is important,
but not as important as the
other blocks.
If you have created all this,
the last can be done by any
newbie.
Also, they can keep looking at
the syntax in the Internet and
they can do that, but a lot of
newbies believe if they know a
lot of programming languages,
they're smart.
Not at all.
Yeah, that is just the last
step.
It is just translating a
solution into code which you can
do it in Java, Python, swift,
whatever you like and that will
keep changing.
But this aspect of understanding
a problem, determining how to
design what to design, designing
it, analyzing it.
This is what is problem solving
techniques which is important.
Yeah, that is also one of the
learning objectives of this
course.
Cool.
So now let's have a quick
outlook of what we are going to
learn in this course.
Yeah, I'll.
I'll quickly run away.
Yeah.
So don't you know, bother too
much about it?
Because I'm just giving you an
outlook of what all are there in
store for you?
Yeah, we're not actually going
detailed today.
Yeah, we learned something
called as data structures for
the first half of the semester,
meaning till your mid semester
exam, we are not even going to
learn about algorithm design.
Yeah.
If you remember our course name,
it is called data structures and
algorithm design.
Yeah, there are two parts in it.
One is data structures, one is
algorithm design.
So data structures is what we
will look at in the first half
of the semester and algorithm
design is what we will look at
in the second half of the
semester.
But they're all very related.
Yeah, you cannot write an
algorithm without a data
structure and so on.
Yeah.
In data structures,
particularly, we will learn
about arrays.
We will learn about linked list.
We will learn something called
as a stack.
We will learn something called
as a queue.
We will learn hash tables.
We will learn about trees.
Yeah, it is called a
hierarchical data structure and
we will learn a lot of types of
trees.
We will learn about heaps.
We will learn about AVL trees,
graphs and all that.
We will learn and we will take a
pause in the eighth session and
after the mid semester exam we
will start with something called
less algorithmic techniques.
Yeah.
So for example, if you have a
lock like this which is having 3
digits and say I have forgotten
the password, will I be able to
unlock this?
No, no, that is what I was
telling others.
Yeah, they are all related.
You will still have algorithms,
but based on these concepts
there might be an algorithm
asked on tree.
There might be, you know,
algorithm based on heap and so
on.
Yeah.
We will not actually look at the
algorithmic techniques per say
that we will do it after the mid
semester, but we will learn some
algorithms even before the
midterm.
Also today all combinations from
you know. Start.
Yeah, that's a smart answer,
right?
So what we will do if I have all
the time in the world, I will
start from 000001002 up to 999
and one of them should be the
password and definitely it will
get unlocked.
So in this did I use my mind or
did I just use my time to just
try everything? Yeah.
Should I put in any of my?
You know mine to use.
No, I had all the time in the
world.
I just started trying every
possible combination and
whatever works works this type
of problem solving is called
brute force.
Yeah, this is called brute
force, meaning brute force
algorithms are exactly what they
sound like straightforward
method for solving a problem
that rely on sheer computing
power and trying every
possibility rather than advanced
techniques to improve
efficiency.
Right, it is not efficient
because you're randomly trying
every possible combination.
Yeah, you have the time.
You can do it.
Yeah, but it has its own
problems.
You will look at it later in
this course.
So you will have to learn about
advanced techniques.
Yeah.
So those techniques we will
learn in this course after the
mid semester, right, so that is
what are these techniques like
greedy technique divide and
conquer, dynamic programming and
so on.
So these are not algorithms.
These are algorithms, strategies
or.
These are algorithm techniques.
There are thousands of
algorithms under greedy
technique.
There are again thousands of
algorithms under a divide and
conquer.
You get it right, it it is a
school of thought.
It is more of a ideology.
Yeah.
So divide and conquer is an
ideology. It says.
Always divide the problem into
smaller bits.
Try to solve each smaller
individual bit.
It simply means you have solved
the bigger problem right?
So it is an ideology.
It is not an algorithm by
itself.
There are plenty of algorithms
which follow this ideology.
Similarly, greedy technique,
dynamic programming and so on.
There are many more techniques
also like branch and bound
randomization, genetic
algorithms and so on, but those
are not in scope of this course.
You will only be majorly
focusing on these three
techniques and we will take a
couple of examples of algorithms
which fall under this strategy
and we will learn about all that
after the mindset and in the
last two classes, we will also
learn about something called as
complexity classes.
Yeah, there are a lot of
problems even today which cannot
be solved efficiently.
Yeah.
We will try to ask about will
there be a time when you know we
will be able to solve everything
efficiently?
Is that even possible?
If you encounter a problem which
is not solvable efficiently,
then what do you do?
Yeah.
Should we just leave it or you
know if a client comes up with
the problem, which is a, you
know, very difficult problem, it
cannot be solved effectively.
Then what is that you're going
to do?
Maybe you have to make money.
You're going to, you know, sell
the product to them.
You are going to make a deal.
So how do you go about working
your way around?
What are the other ways for
these type of you know problems
right?
We will try to learn about all
that in the last two classes.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you?
Yeah. Travelling salesman.
Not not just that there are
hundreds of problems like that,
yeah.
Yes.
No.
Maybe all of you.
So first two classes we are
going to just learn about
algorithm analyzing an algorithm
and so on.
And then we will look at data
structures, data structures.
We will look to say for a good
6-7 classes we will look at it
and then again we will start
algorithms, strategies.
We will learn all that and
finally we will close this
course with what are those
algorithms which are still
challenging mankind and will
there ever be a time when we
will be able to solve them
effectively, right.
So all such discussions we will
do, then we will close the
course.
Is this clear?
Because always you should have a
big picture of what is it that
I'm doing in this course?
Yeah, later you can actually
learn it.
Yeah, but at least you should
have a fair idea about how the
course is progressing.
Where do we release stand?
Yeah, these are all important
questions that you need to know,
right?
A quick progress check.
This is what we have done right?
We have taken some introduction
motivation about handout and all
that and we also looked at some
basics of notion of an
algorithm.
Which properties?
And so on, right?
Is that clear?
Days. Yeah.
We'll we'll have a look at a
couple of more slides and then
we'll take a quick break, yeah.
This is question who's the
champion?
Yeah.
What is the meaning of?
Yeah.
We will come back to that when
we come there.
Yeah, it is called polynomial,
nondeterministic polynomial and
all that.
But any algorithm which can be
solved effectively is called P
class.
Yeah, polynomial class.
Don't worry about that.
Yeah.
We will learn about it in detail
when the time comes.
Who's the champion?
There's Sachin.
There's Doni, there is Virat,
there's Zahir. Yeah.
Yeah, you have just come out of
the World Cup drama, I believe.
But yeah, go ahead.
Who's the champion among these
four? Yeah.
Yes, real quick.
Tell them are diplomatic, like
all of them.
Some of them don't need wrath
and so on, but if I were you, I
will ask the next question on
what metric?
Yeah, you are showing, you know,
champion on what terms when it's
the total number of runs.
You know, Sachin, maybe if it's
the number of cups, then it is
Dhoni.
If it's wickets, then undeniable
it, Zahir and so on.
So then in this question,
correct, who's the champion?
When I ask that question, you
suddenly started replaying the
only Virat and all that.
The thing is, we should ask on
what criteria on what metric, on
what terms should I answer you
right?
That should have been your next
question.
Yeah.
Similarly, in algorithms, when
there are two correct solutions
right?
For example, here I want to know
since you know, let's believe
the whole course is over and I
want to know who's the Topper in
the DSDT course.
And I hope you know the Topper
is maybe 100.
Let's see.
I've given the problem to two
students.
Yeah.
So one is, say, Amit and another
I have given it to say you know.
Vertica.
Yeah, how they have solved this
is vertika is, you know, quickly
sorted them in descending order.
Yeah, once you sorted in
descending order, the toppers
mark will be the first one.
So we can just take it as a one
when you write it in algorithms,
you can write it like this.
Actually this is a zero that is
also fine.
This is fine or the other way.
The other way, Amit, how he has
done it is he has taken a loop.
He has, you know, compared all
of them.
He kept on checking.
Who's the largest Marks and the
largest mark?
Yes.
Found out.
Yeah.
Are both of these algorithms
correct?
Will both of them give me the
toppest mark in this course?
Yeah.
All of you.
What do you think?
Yes, both of them are correct.
Yeah, both of them are going to
give me the correct answer.
It is going to give me the top
most mark now, which is better,
right?
So again, this is a very
ambiguous question, right?
Which is better?
Meaning how is it based on, you
know which metric similar to our
cricket question we told give me
some metrics, is it based on
wickets?
Is it based on hundreds?
Is it based on number of World
Cups?
One as a captain, what is it?
Similarly, for an algorithm, we
will have two main criterias.
Yeah.
One is called the running time,
one is called the space used.
Yeah, running time means lesser.
The running time better be
algorithm, right?
And the space used means lesser
the space used better the
algorithm, but off late for the
last couple of years, the space
complexity is not.
You know very much important
these days because of, you know,
a lot of advanced techniques.
Hardware has become cheap.
You're able to store tons of
data even in main memory.
There are advanced strategies
like you know your master slave
architectures, right, your
Hadoop architecture and so on.
So space is not a very big
problem.
Of course, there are researchers
still working on all this, but
if you are application
developer, if you are just going
to solve problems, if you are
not going to do research and so
on, then all that you are going
to be concerned is the running
time of it, not the space
complexity.
So in this whole course, we will
be focusing a lot on the running
time, right?
The one which runs faster are
better algorithms.
Is this clear for all of you?
Yes.
No.
Maybe are the metrics clear,
right?
Any algorithm that you evaluate,
you'll be evaluating based on
the time complexity.
The lesser the time it takes,
the better it is.
Yeah.
And it is again proportional to
the size of it, right?
If you have just two numbers
versus sorting 2000 numbers, it
is not the same, right?
It is going to take more time.
It is going to take more space
and you know it is proportional
to your input.
Like these question, why not
consider space?
So yeah, you can do that.
Yeah, if you have, you know you
can also consider that, but it
is not relatively important
these days because space is
becoming cheaper, right?
I can store a lot of data.
Also, I don't have a problem
with that right back in those
days.
Space was also constrained.
Yeah, there were constraints on
don't use extra data structures.
Don't keep using variables right
then there was a problem with
space.
That is why you know, it was a
very big deal, but today also
for a couple of problems, it is
still necessary and so on or
when your architecture becomes
tricky, right when you are given
very constrained resources that
you are going to run your
solution in a smart watch which
has only say you know 182 or you
know bits or something, then
your whole, you know space
complexity also comes in, right.
So now we have already learned
about better means you know more
efficient algorithm is based on
time and space.
But how do you measure the
running time of an algorithm?
Please give a few more examples
to understand resource usage.
Are resource means it is only
two?
Yeah, it is your time and your
space and your CPU and all that.
What we are meaning is it is
proportional to the input size,
right?
For example, if I'm telling you
to add, say 2 numbers, right?
Adding two numbers and adding
2,00,000 numbers.
Is it the same right now for two
numbers, the time complexity and
space complexity will be lesser.
Whereas when you have 2,00,000
numbers it is more.
That is what we are telling that
the resources needed by your
algorithm is proportional to the
input.
If you have a larger input, then
of course you will have a larger
complexity, right?
Cool.
So what about this?
It's all fine.
Time complexity, space
complexity, lesser the time,
lesser the space.
It is better understood, but how
do I measure the running time of
an algo?
Yeah, one way to do that is
experimental studies.
Yeah, what I can do is you know,
I'll, I'll give you those same
two people, right.
What they can do is they will
try to write that program.
They will all, you know, the
algorithm.
They'll implement it and they
will try to run it on different
data sets of varying size and
what they can do is they can put
like a time stamp, right.
In Java you can do something
like system dot current timely
second or in Python you can do
time it.
If you put that, it will just
print the time stamp it took to
run the you know program.
So you can keep, you know,
running like that and you will
plot it in a graph like this,
where for example if 10 is the
input it took, you know say 8
milliseconds.
When, say, 50 is your N means
input, when your input is 50
elements then it took say maybe
around, you know 13 milliseconds
and so on.
So you will plot a graph like
this.
Both of them will have plotted
their graphs.
You'll compare those two graphs
and you will be able to see
which one of them is better.
What do you see?
Any problems with this?
Yeah, real quick, guys, do you
see any problems with this
approach when you want to
measure running time through
you?
Always.
You know, write a program, run
it, put a time stamp, put a
graph and all this right.
There is a lot of problems in
this, yeah, several limitations.
First things first, it is
necessary to implement and test
the algorithm in order to
determine its running time.
Yeah.
First of all, both of them
should be aware of
implementation.
Yeah.
What if Amit is implementing in
say, assembly language and
vertika is doing it in say a
high level language like Java?
Yeah, I think I know only Java.
She is doing it in Java.
It is Amit on the other extreme.
He goes ahead and writes the
whole solution.
His algorithm in assembly
language?
Which of them will be fast?
It's a no brainer, right?
Assembly language directly, you
know.
We'll get translated to your
binary and it'll go execute,
whereas your Java has a lot of
other steps.
Your JVM compilation, whatnot,
right?
So then you are not comparing
the same things right?
You are comparing an apple with
an orange, which is a problem,
right?
So that is the first problem and
first of all you should know
about the language, correct?
Someone should know a
programming language to even
implement it.
So does problem solving need
programming skills?
Yeah.
So this whole field is called CT
right?
Computational thinking.
Computational thinking is not
equal to programming.
Yeah, there can be someone who
can solve any problem, but he
cannot necessarily code it.
He doesn't know any programming
language.
It is possible.
Yeah, I know a lot of people,
even school kids these days.
Yeah, there are a lot of school
kids who don't know any
programming, but they are
computationally very strong.
Yeah, they will be able to give
a solution to the problem,
right?
This is what in RH or maybe you
know back in those days we used
to call puzzles and so on.
You remember those?
They used to be a book full of
puzzles.
Yeah.
Where you just solved the
puzzle.
You are not writing any code
there, right?
But every puzzle is nothing but
a problem, right?
You're trying to solve the
puzzle.
It is nothing but solving, you
know, an actual computing
problem. Right?
Right.
So computational thinking and
programming is not the same.
So if some people are there who
are able to solve the puzzles or
give me solutions, but they
don't know programming, then how
will you compare it so that is
the first limitation.
Firstly, you need to implement
it, which is extra time effort.
All that which is a problem.
Second one experiments can be
done only on a limited set of
input and may not be indicative
of the running time of other
inputs.
So here you are only running it
for these many inputs.
You're not running it for all
the inputs possible, right?
So that is again a problem when
you talk about experiment, it
becomes limited.
You cannot consider everything
right and then second, this is
not hardware software agnostic,
correct?
For example, in this case a
Vertica is using a I-9 processor
and Amit on the other hand is
running, say our dual core
system.
Or an old Pentium system.
Right.
Again, you are not comparing the
same right one is the latest
architecture which has so many
registers and it is very fast,
whereas on the other hand you
have, you know, a very old
system.
Then again, are you doing
justice by comparing?
Not really right.
So again, there is a problem.
So if experimental studies is
not the way to evaluate running
time, then how do we do this?
Got any ideas guys?
You are real quick.
Any ideas?
We just agreed that
experimentation is not a great
way because you have to
implement.
You should have exactly the same
software, same hardware, exactly
same configurations, and then
you'll have to run it.
It is not always possible,
right?
That is why we go about a
standard model, which is called
an analytical model, right?
We all will now imagine a
machine in mind, and in that
machine we will all try to
analyze our algorithms.
That machine is the analytical
model.
We will now develop a general
methodology for analyzing the
running time of algorithms.
Very important guys.
Yeah, all of you.
Yeah, it is not big go big Theta
and so on.
Yeah, don't get confused.
Yeah, we'll learn about that
also, but this is not that.
Yeah, all of you here back
again?
Yeah, we learned that
experimental studies has a lot
of limitation.
I'll have to run it in, you
know, put a time stamp.
Put a graph, compare it.
It should all be same hardware
software.
I should implement it.
All these disadvantages are
there, so we will not do that.
It will be so cool if I can
directly evaluate an algorithm.
Yeah, that is what we will do.
So we are going to develop a
general model uses a high level
description of the algorithm
instead of testing one of its
implementations, we will not
write the algorithm at all.
Yeah.
Take into account all possible
inputs.
Yeah, and allows one to evaluate
the efficiency of any algorithm
in a way that is independent
from the hardware and software.
Right.
And what is that model?
Of course, these are all
dependent the running time
depends on, you know single
processor or multiprocessor.
Read write speed.
The input given, and so on.
So that is why we are now coming
to a general model and that is
called RAM.
Yeah, Ramesh stands for random
access machine.
This is not your RAM, ROM.
Yeah, that one.
Yeah, this is a imaginary
machine.
Yeah, it is a machine
independent way to analyze
algorithms.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you, is there a
real machine like this?
Yes it does, right?
Because if you have 32 bit 264
bit based on how much you can
store what is your, you know
register size, what is your
clock speed?
All that matters, right?
That is why you have your cost,
subject, analytical model means
it's a link between system
description and design model
description.
Yeah, it is more of an imaginary
machine where we all will try to
analyze our algorithms.
I wrote algorithm.
You write algorithm a someone
else writes BCD.
We will not run it in systems.
We will all imagine this in our
mind and we will try to analyze
our algorithm on this machine.
Yeah, we're all bringing them
into a fair ground.
Yeah.
Does it make sense?
All of you.
This machine doesn't exist in
reality.
Correct.
It is called random access
machine.
It is a model.
It is just a model computer.
Yeah, this model assumes a
single processor.
Yeah, it is not having many
processors and all that it is
having just one processor in the
RAM model.
Instructions are executed one
after the other with no
concurrent operation.
This model doesn't allow that
line by line, only it can
execute this model of
computation.
Is an abstraction that allows us
to compare algorithms on the
basis of performance.
Now both of them right will use
this model.
They're not run it in their own
computers and put a graph and
all that.
Both of them will imagine this
machine.
The assumptions made in the RAM
model to accomplish this are
each simple operation takes one
time unit.
Yeah, every operation you do
addition, that is one time unit,
you do assignment.
That is one time unit.
Every operation, simple
operation we will learn about
this in the next few slides
takes one time.
Unit loops and subroutines are
not simple operation, right?
If you have a loop, it has many
other simple operation.
If you have a subroutine or
function that has a lot more
simple operations within it, so
you should not call that as
simple operation and each memory
access takes one time unit again
and there is no shortage of
memory, we believe there is
unbounded memory.
Yeah, there's no problem with
memory.
Is what this model assumes
right?
For example, you have the
location counter where you have
the next instruction to run.
You have the program.
It is going and fetching from
thing from my input tape.
How many time units does it
take?
Yeah, real quick guys.
We learned that in the RAM model
one time unit you go fetch
something.
It is one time unit.
You are going and writing an
output somewhere.
How many time units is that?
There is also one time unit.
Yeah.
And if I want to, you know, go
ahead and read the memory.
You see the dots here, right?
It is dot dot dot meaning it is
unbounded.
All the memory that you want is
available.
That is what this model offers
you.
Right then the time complexity
or running time becomes the
number of instructions executed
and space complexity becomes the
number of memory cells accessed.
Simple right?
So all of you understood the RAM
model, the RAM model is needed
because experimental studies are
not very effective.
They have several limitations,
so all of us are now in the same
pitch.
When I give you a new problem to
solve, all of you will solve it
in different different ways, but
all of you will analyze in this
model in mind.
You will imagine you are going
to run your solution in this
model.
Yeah.
Chandra, which part is not
clear?
The random access machine is a
imaginary machine.
It is not existing right.
It is a machine which has a lot
of assumptions that it has only
one processor.
It has, you know, any operation
takes one time unit.
There is unbounded memory.
These are all the assumptions of
that imaginary computer, and
whenever we want to analyze our
algorithm, we will go to this
model.
We will imagine that this is the
machine where my algorithm is
going to run and we are going to
analyze it in that way.
All of us are coming to the same
page.
Otherwise you will implement it
and run it in I7 processor.
I will do it in, you know, I3.
There will be a lot of
discrepancies.
I will write it in Java.
You will write it in binary,
right?
There are problems, so we are
all coming to the same page by
coming to this model.
Is that clear?
Yes.
No, all of you.
Is this a common model used?
Practically, nowadays, yes, it
is still used.
Yeah, it is a fundamental of
theoretical computer science and
it is still used, yeah.
We take a very short break.
Yeah, we'll come back in 5
minutes and we will continue
from here, yeah.
Meanwhile, I'll still be around
if you have any other general
questions or anything we can
chat about that.
Yeah, a couple of you had raised
hands.
The hands still remains.
I will come back in just five
minutes and then we'll again
continue, yeah.
Yeah, there's a question, sorry,
off topic.
When we visit the campus, yes,
of course you can.
There is no actual need.
We'll students need not come to
campus, but if you just want to
visit, then you can.
But but you'll not know anyone
there, right?
All your faculties are off
campus faculties.
So in the actual campus, you
will not know anyone, you will
not have any, you know work to
do.
You will not be allowed into
hostels or all that.
Yeah, just to give a glimpse, of
course you can.
And uh, your seniors, of course,
they have also started, you
know, something new where, you
know, they had a conversation
also.
Yeah, I know.
Hyderabad campus last week 19th
there was a convocation for will
students specifically.
Yeah, but not everyone will be
invited because there is, you
know, a lot of students in WILP.
So maybe someone who has scored
well, or someone who's very
genuinely interested they can,
you know, write an email and,
you know, attend it.
Concurrent operations are not
possible.
Render model yes.
Yeah, Prakriti are right.
That model doesn't allow it.
Yeah, there are other models
also, but we will always stick
to this model and it doesn't
allow concurrent operation.
How do we know the number of
memory cells accessed without
writing some code directly from
the pseudo code we will get to
know that Santosh yeah we will
learn about that further today,
yeah.
Directly we will be able to know
in RAM.
We have a standard way of
performing experimental study.
Which language is used here?
No, we don't have any
experimental study at all here.
Yeah, we will proceed further.
You will get a better hang of
it, yeah.
So their placement in this
program, no, it is not because
this whole program relies on the
fundamental aspect that you are
already employed.
Yeah, the name itself is work
integrated learning, so it
believes that you are already
employed.
Yeah, there is no point in again
giving you, you know, placement
support and all that.
Yeah, yeah.
Location counter.
You'll also learn it in your
cost, subject, computer
organization.
It is a type of a register where
you have the address of the next
line in the program to execute.
It is also called as program
counter in some you know authors
prefer to call it that way.
I want to know what is the next
line to execute right?
I'll not know otherwise, so this
counter will have the address of
the next location.
Yeah, but it that's right.
Yeah.
Are these PPTS available in
canvas?
No, it is not yet available, but
immediately after the class it
will be available.
I will not upload slides.
Well in advance, but immediately
after my class.
That is my practice.
If the class ends by 10:30
within 1040, you will be able to
see the slides.
In which industry?
Data science is used.
I mean now it is penetrating to
every industry.
Yeah, it's not just one.
Yeah.
So where exactly do we use RAM?
Like it is embedded inside OS or
no it is not even there guys.
Yeah.
So yeah, again getting confused.
Ram is an imaginary machine.
Just think about it like another
machine, right?
Just like your laptop or my
laptop, it is an imaginary
machine and whenever we talk
about algorithm analysis, this
machine comes to our mind,
right?
It has certain assumptions that
every operation takes 1 unit and
so on, which all of us will
adhere to.
That is all.
It is not a real thing like
where it is an OS or it is a
machine.
It is not a real thing.
Yeah, like a mind machine. Yeah.
Flights will be available in
teams canvas both, right?
No, it will be available in only
canvas.
As I told, teams is only for
live classes as well as
recordings.
Everything else will be there in
your canvas.
Yeah, there's a lot of
questions.
We'll just wait for another
minute and get started, guys.
Yeah, please explain this model
machine.
Yeah, that is what we learned,
right?
It is a model machine which has
these assumptions.
It is going to have a single
processor.
It can execute only instructions
line after line.
It cannot do multiple
instructions at the same time,
and so on.
Every operation takes one time
unit and it is having unbounded
memory.
How many ever instructions you
run that becomes the total time,
and so on.
And there's more about this in
your text.
Yeah.
And also you know I have a look
at that isram used to analyse
space complexity of algorithms
time.
Both can be used.
That is what this line right?
The number of memory cell
accessed is that space
complexity.
The number of instructions
executed is the time complexity.
So how we manually do the
performance testing using RAM if
we want to do in real time
scenario real time scenario we
will not do that.
Is the whole point because in
real time the same problem
comes.
You might use some software.
You might use some hardware.
I might use something else
right?
Then how do you compare those
two?
So we will always compare
algorithms only on this
theoretical basis in theoretical
basis.
If mine is better than yours,
which is good enough, right?
We are not concerned about the
actual implementation of it,
because actual implementation
relies on all these factors.
Which programming language I
use?
Which software I use?
Which hardware I use right?
And all these, you know, become
a deal.
In short, when we analyze an
algorithm, we will be managing
the RAM and calculating what
time it will be running exactly.
That's correct.
Yeah, all of you are in the same
page.
Let's proceed ahead.
Yeah.
Yes.
No, maybe.
Cool.
So now you will learn about
something called as pseudo code.
Yeah.
To someone Santosh or in
between, someone asked me like
how do you know how much memory
you are going to access or how?
How do you know?
You know the time complexity
just from the algorithm without
implementing, how will you know,
right?
He was right.
We cannot directly know if you
write an English paragraph
right.
Do you all agree guys, I give
you a problem.
You write an English paragraph.
Will I be able to know anything
out of it?
Will I be able to know what
memory it accesses?
How many lines are there?
I'll not know anything, right?
That is why we are going to come
to a common ground and I might
not know programming language
also, so in order to convey our
solution or idea to fellow human
beings, we are going to come to
a middle ground and that is
called as pseudo code.
Pseudo code is a mixture of
natural language and high level
programming concepts that
describes the main ideas behind
a generic implementation of a
data structure and algorithm.
It is a high level description
of an algorithm.
It is more structured than
English prose, but it is less
detailed than a program.
It is preferred notation for
describing algorithms, and it
hides all the program design
issues.
For example, this is a suedo
code.
There is a pseudo code to find
the maximum element in an array
in the Python currency.
Learned right, RA?
It's a sequence of, you know,
elements, right?
I'm I'm given this array as well
as the number of elements as the
input and I want to find out the
maximum element.
I've written some code here.
If I just go ahead and type this
in, any programming language,
will it execute?
Yeah.
In other words, can we just run
the pseudo code?
No.
Correct, because the name itself
actually, as it says it is
pseudo, it is not real code.
Yeah, it is just pseudo in
nature meaning.
Then why do we need it?
Because we want to communicate
our ideas between fellow human
beings.
Yeah, I might know Python.
You might know SWIFT or Java.
I don't know that you don't know
Python.
Then how will we communicate,
right?
That is one problem.
All the human beings are in
software development.
Experts need not know the same
language, that is point 1.2 is a
normal English.
We will not be able to convey
certain important details right.
For example, are you accessing
memory or not?
Those details we will not be
able to convey in plain English.
So in order to solve both these
problems, we write something
called as a pseudo code.
So in this algorithm, if you see
we take the first element in the
array, put it in a variable
called current Max.
Then we run a loop.
In the loop, we are comparing
each element in the array with
this variable current Max.
If you find some element greater
than your current VMAX, you
update your current Max with
that variable.
Once this loop is over, you will
be able to know that the maximum
element in that array will be
the current maximum.
Yeah, but this particular code,
if you execute in any editor, it
will not, right?
So the code does require
programming language or any
technology to be considered as
just kind of rough draft.
Yeah, it is just rough draft.
There are some rules to write
this.
Also, I will talk about that in
the next slide, right?
For example, this arrow.
This arrow means that
assignment.
It means whatever is in the
right side, you are assigning it
to the left side.
That means assignment, right?
So like this, there are many
rules so we will learn about
those rules in the next slide.
But real quick in this program,
initially what happens, the
current Max will be a 0 which is
10.
Then you start a loop from here
till the end you try to see if
20 is greater than 10.
Yes.
So this current Max line becomes
20.
Then again, you go back to the
loop.
I becomes 2:30 is greater than
20. Yes.
So you are current Max becomes
30 and then I becomes three is 5
greater than 30, No 5 is not
greater than 30.
So this line doesn't execute you
again go back.
I becomes 4 right?
That is nothing but a of I-77
greater than 30.
Is that true?
No.
So this line doesn't execute, so
you are back to the last line
which is return current Max and
this variable has my value 30
and 30 is of course the largest
in this array.
So does this sudocode work at
least successfully conveyed the
idea to all of you?
Yes.
No, I have not written a
program.
This is not going to work, but
all of you now know how to find
out the maximum element in an
array.
You know that you'll keep a
variable.
You will run a loop.
You'll try to update that
variable when you find something
better.
Yeah, this is the pseudo code.
Yeah.
So for all the newbies who have
not done any programming, I'll
again urge you to please, you
know, put that extra effort,
right.
So when these type of pseudo
code or this type is given,
you'll always try to trace this
program, meaning you'll first
see what is current Max current
Max is a zero, what is a zero?
Yeah.
Santosh will tell that Santosh
Kumar yeah, what is a zero is 0
is the first element here which
is 10.
So this current Max is going to
have 10 and then what happens?
I is initialized to one and then
you go in a of I what is a of 1.
Now a of one is 20, so you're
comparing 20 with 10 point is
greater than 10 is true, so you
are coming in and current Max
now becomes 20 and Now this line
is over.
You go back to the loop, right?
You see the indentation right?
So these two lines are the body
of the for loop, so you again go
back and I becomes now three,
right?
I becomes two, so A of two.
What is a of two now a of two?
Nothing but 30 right now, 30 is
greater than 20 because current
Max was already updated, right?
So this keeps happening till the
loop is over and at the end of
the day the current Max will
have that answer 30.
Yeah.
Is that clear? Yeah.
Santosh, for Sudocode also block
of statements to identify.
Not necessary.
Yeah, that was already gone.
OK, cool.
So some rules, right?
Someone was asking Leno how do
we write this sudo code?
Are there any rules?
Yes, right.
As we saw, it is structured than
usual text.
It is not very simple like
English.
There should be some structure
to it, meaning there is some
intention here.
There are some keywords like do
then right.
It is a little structured, but
not as formal as a programming
language.
Control flows.
You can use just like you know
if then while repeat or you can
use this intermediation replaces
braces.
You can use that you can use
method declaration like.
This is what my program is going
to do, right and some
expressions like these like
assignment you will do using
arrow like this is equal to your
equal to in programming language
right in C, Java or Python A
equal to 10.
In this you will do a this arrow
10 right.
This arrow means assignment.
Here in pseudo code equal to
means equality testing right
when you want to check for, you
know some variables are equal or
not right.
For example, if you want to know
if a is equal equal to five,
this you will do it in
programming language.
But in seudo code you can do it
as a equal to 5, correct?
Similarly, assignment in normal
languages you will do it as say
is equal to temp whereas in
pseudo code you will do like
this and this arrow means
assignment and this equal to
means comparison and similarly
in any programming language will
you be able to directly use
these type of superscripts.
Have you ever returned?
Like you know, in a program
directly I less than N square.
You cannot do that, right?
You have to do N into north or
north into 2, something like
that.
But in your pseudo code, it's
liberal, right?
You can directly write in square
and all that because at the end
it is just for human beings to
understand.
The purpose is not to run it on
a computer, right?
So we will be able to get to
know about it.
Yeah.
Is this clear for all of you?
What is the pseudo code?
Pseudocode is just to
communicate between human
beings, right?
It is not going to run on a
computer.
It is more formal than English.
It is less formal than a
programming language and a lot
of essence of the program can be
conveyed in it.
Yeah, which is also going to
help us in evaluating our codes.
Yeah, so far so good, guys.
All of you?
Yes.
No.
Maybe we'll proceed ahead when I
do N square is it will count as.
Yeah, it will count as
operation.
Yeah, we will look at that.
Now that is what is called
primitive operation.
Yeah, primitive operations are
also called as basic operations
or they are the heart of an
algorithm and it is identifiable
in pseudo code.
That's the good news, right?
Anyway, once we write the you
know code, we will be able to
identify it.
It is largely independent from
the programming language, right?
And it is assumed to take a
constant amount of time in the
RAM model.
And what is that constant
amount?
You already know it.
Yeah.
I mean to two also you can do
Rajesh.
Yeah, no problem.
Yeah.
One very good.
Yeah, one time in it.
What are the examples of
primitive operations?
Yeah, evaluating an expression.
Yeah.
For example, A+B, that is one
time unit.
That is a primitive operation.
Assigning a value to a variable,
primitive operation, indexing
into an array.
Yeah.
Santosh had a question.
How do I know if I'm accessing
memory or not?
Yeah, you will get to know here
if I'm using a line like a of
zero, it means I'm going to the
memory.
I'm looking at this array a I'm
picking up this zeroth location
value, so I'm accessing the
memory so this is a primitive
operation.
Calling a method returning from
a method, meaning that return
line that is a primitive
operation, right?
So there are a lot more
examples.
You can have a look at your
book, but what is not a
primitive operation?
Can you come with some examples?
Primitive operation means the
basic operation right.
The heart of each statement.
Yeah, looping very good.
A loop has several components,
right?
You have to increment.
You have to do condition
checking first time your
initializing.
It is made up of multiple
primitive operations.
Again, sorting right, all these
are not primitive operations.
Cool.
So now can we analyze and
algorithms complexity just from
a pseudo code?
Yes, this is possible.
So this technique is very, very
important.
That is what we are going to
learn analyzing the pseudo code
or analyzing the time complexity
by using counting primitives,
right?
This is called the counting
method.
Yeah, let's go over this and
then try to do it actually.
Yeah, try to have a look at this
close.
Look at it for each line of the
pseudo code, count the number of
primitive operations in it.
Pay attention to the word
primitive, because sorting an
array is not a primitive
operation, right?
Multiply this count with the
number of times this line is
executed, some up all the lines
and you will get a final answer.
You agree to this.
Yes.
No.
Maybe all of you, but so far is
the story clear.
We are going to analyze
algorithms.
We need it because multiple
people can write a correct
solution.
Then I want to know who's better
right Karanbir also has given me
a correct solution in.
Simran also has given Rajesh
also has given then who's
better, right?
I want to know who's better.
That is why we analyze
algorithms, right?
But to analyze that algorithm,
we wanted a common ground and we
all agreed upon a common ground.
What is that?
Yeah, real quick.
What was that common ground in a
common machine is where all of
us will analyze our algorithm.
We will not run it on our own
laptops.
Right Ram model, right?
Random access machine.
Perfect.
And then should we all write
programs?
No.
What did we say?
We will all write sudo codes for
whatever problem is given.
We will write a pseudo code and
we are imagining that pseudo
code will run on that RAM model.
Is that story clear so far?
Once this is clear that pseudo
code, you take it in hand every
line try to inspect it and see
how many primitive operations
are there and then try to
multiply that primitive
operation with the number of
times that line executes and
then Add all of that.
We will see an example.
It will be even more clear.
Yeah, let's look at this.
So this is going to print the
elements of an array.
What is this code doing?
All I is equal to 0 while I is
less than N print A of I I plus
plus.
So what is it ultimately going
to do?
It is just going to take an
array and print all of its
elements.
Yeah, I've just written a small
piece of code right this I plus
plus.
Also you can write it as I is
equal to I + 1.
That is the correct way.
Yeah, you need not write this is
this clear guys?
This is seudo code, right?
We have written it.
Now we are going to analyze this
right?
How do you analyze this?
I have taken the same piece line
by line.
Yeah.
What will be the input?
The input is already known,
which is an array with elements.
Yeah, I'm given some yen.
I'm having that actual array A
so that is what is given to us.
Yeah, it is all known.
Yeah, it is not defined because
this is audio code that then can
be anything.
It can be fine and it means it
can be fine at elements.
I'm not bothered about it, I
just know that whatever an
elements are given, I'm going to
print it, yeah.
We will not know the loop
addressing the.
We will not know it, but yeah,
that is the whole beauty.
Yeah.
Now you're all probing the right
questions without even knowing
all that.
I will still be able to analyze
this program.
Yeah, that is the beauty.
Let's do that.
So does this little code?
Yeah.
Now, how do you analyze that
using counting primitive?
We will be going line by line
the very first line.
How many times it is going to
execute and is it having any
primitive operation?
Yeah, all of you.
Please don't jump the bridge.
Yeah, it'll be very intimidating
for others.
Yeah, we'll go line by line in
the first line.
Is there any primitive
operation?
What is that primitive
operation?
Yeah.
We are going to assign that zero
right?
So this is technically not a
pseudo code.
Yeah, this is semi.
Yeah, you should have it like an
arrow, right?
So this is going to do 1 unit,
right, one initialization of Y,
only one time it is going to
happen, right?
Every time I is not going to get
assigned, so only one time and
then there is this while loop.
How many times will this while
loop execute?
That is my Western inside that
there is a operator.
This is a comparison operator
which is going to take one unit
of time, but how many times will
it execute?
Yeah, we don't need syntax
Surendran.
Yeah, you can just put it
normally.
Also no problem, yeah.
Yen plus one, right?
If you clearly see the last time
also the comparison will happen,
but then the comparison will
fail at that time.
Correct.
So N + 1 number of times.
What about the body of these two
lines?
Yeah, if this is N + 1, the last
plus one time the Bloop will
fail and come out, so the body
will execute N times, right?
But look at this line in this
particular print line.
What are the primitive
operations?
Yeah, let's try to identify the
primitive operation.
What are those?
Yeah, indexing correct a of I is
nothing but indexing.
That is 1 primitive operation.
What else is there?
Yeah, you identified.
You got it.
Then you're printing it right
print.
So this is also a primitive
operation, right?
So there are two primitive
operations, right?
So N array indexing operations
are there, right?
And every time that line
executes, there are two
primitive operations that is
happening right that is north
invocation of print right and
then increments of I.
Right.
So we just try to Add all of
that and we will.
So for the time being, don't
worry about this small, you
know, plus 1 -, 1 and all that
in a couple of slides we will
look at the, you know,
significance that they're all
not important.
Yeah, don't worry about that.
Please do this for another
program.
I love to do it in a tabular
way.
You can also prefer to do this
way.
Yeah.
First, let's look at what this
is doing.
The first column I'm writing the
actual pseudo code in the second
column I'm counting the number
of primitive operations in that
line, and in the third column
I'm giving some remarks.
First things first, if you look
at this first column, what is it
that it is doing?
Arrison it is taking an array as
input with N elements.
It is going to Add all the
elements in that array.
That is what it is.
It is going to do is the code
self explanatory?
I've taken the first element in
some.
I have a variable.
Uh, you know, I I run a while
loop.
I add each element with the sum
variable and store it in some
itself and I increment I.
I'll keep doing this while loop,
third step and when the while
loop fails, I'll come back and
my sum will have the total sum
of the array.
I'll return it.
Yeah, is the first column clear
for all of you real quick guys,
yeah.
Now what is the next step?
You have returned the code.
The next step is to analyze it.
How do you analyze it?
People use the counting
primitive method and this is
going to assume the RAM model
right?
This pseudo code is going to run
on the RAM machine, right?
Let's apply the counting
primitive.
So in the first line, how many
primitive operations are there?
There are two right there.
Is this indexing there?
Is this assignment so that is
what I have given as a comment.
Indexing is also happening,
meaning a zero.
I go to that memory and take
that element that is indexing
and then assignment is also
happening.
Yeah.
So in a lot of uh, you know, use
cases, people instead of writing
that, you know this type of
arrow people put equal to also
it is known.
Yeah, nobody's going to, you
know, tell that it is wrong and
so on, because there's just to
communicate between humans.
Yeah, it is still fine, right?
So I have assigned it I equal to
1 only one operation assignment
right?
And these lines are going to
execute only once, right?
What about this one?
I list Danian how many
comparisons are going to happen
in while loop while here?
Yeah, there also that is what I
was telling.
Don't worry about that.
Plus 1 -, 1, because in a couple
of slides you will realize that
none of that is important.
We are going to anyway delete
all of that.
Yeah, even if you want, you can
put that. No problem.
Yeah.
So I less than N how many times
this line is going to execute?
I suppose my eyes 5 right
initially for is equal to 180
execute for two it'll execute.
For three, it execute for four
at execute for.
If I execute I will become six,
right?
But here if you see is less than
yen, right.
If N was five, how many times
will it execute for 1234 for
this statement?
What will it become by less than
five?
That line still executed right?
That line still executed, but it
became false and then we came
out of the loop.
So how many times did it execute
it?
Execute the end times or N + 1
times.
Yeah.
Yes, you can use either this
arrow or you can put equal to.
Also, it is not a problem.
Yeah, both are accepted.
So and times only, it executes
if this operation was I less
than or equal to yen right then
it will be N + 1 number of
times.
Yeah, always trace it, no
problem.
But in a couple of slides,
you'll realize all this is not
needed.
Yeah, so it's fine.
If this is, then what is the
body of the loop?
It will be and minus One North
minus one times it will execute,
but how many operations are
there in this line there is
array indexing.
There is addition.
There is assignment, so three
operations are there and minus
one times indexing.
Is there addition is there
assignment?
Is there similarly here there
are two operations addition is
there assignment is there so two
operations and then finally
there is this only one time
you're returning and that line
is outside the loop.
So only once it is going to
execute.
So now can I submit the second
column and plus one the other is
right?
Yeah, Chandramouli bang on.
I'll just, you know, add this
complete second column and I
will get an answer so far is
this story clear?
Whatever I program I give you,
you will first write a pseudo
code and then every line you
will inspect.
You will try to see how many
primitive operations it is
having, and then you'll also be
a little careful about loops.
How many times it executes
finally that whole column you
will submit it and keep it,
yeah.
So far so good.
Yeah.
Can you please repeat the North
minus one logic?
Yeah, so simple statements.
And then if the actual loop line
executes the end times, the body
of it right will execute N minus
one number of times.
If the actual loop line executes
N + 1 number of times, the body
of it will execute the end
times, right one less than that.
That is it.
There's a while statement by
itself is not primitive.
No, it is not.
It is a keyword, yeah.
So the compiler knows that
there's a loop, so it is not a
primitive operation in itself.
Cool, but don't don't worry too
much about it.
You will remember this in a
while.
So so far it is good.
You try to get something like
this at the end, yeah.
Now let's proceed ahead and
let's talk about something
called as running time.
Yeah, but iteration depends on.
I correct it all dependent on I
only yeah.
Why we are competing it as n -,
1 did not understand.
Yeah, condition is not
satisfying, right?
So for you, I will try to, you
know, take some values, take a
value of I take a value of yen
and try to trace that program.
Right.
Say suppose I want to print and
my end value is 3, right?
I have a condition I less than
yen.
So initially I is equal to 1,
one less than three is true, so
it will execute the body, it'll
execute the body.
Are you becomes 22 less than
three is true.
It'll execute the body.
It becomes three book 3 less
than three.
This line executed right, but it
gave me an answer as false.
So this body is not executed
right?
So that condition line.
How many times did it execute?
So if you see here once, twice,
thrice, it executed that line.
So it executed number of times,
so three times that line
executed whereas whatever is
there in the body of it this
time it executed.
Here it executed but here it
failed because this condition
failed.
I didn't execute the body, so
only two times it executed.
So 2 is what N minus one.
That is what I was telling.
If I less than North is the
condition then this condition
line will execute N times and
it's body will execute n -, 1
number of times.
Was that clear?
Alita Hall of you, yeah.
If it is less than or equal to,
then it will change.
The third one will also execute
the next time I would have
become four, right?
That line would have got
executed 4 less than three will
still execute this line and then
it would have given false, so
body will not execute so.
But this line still executed, so
n + 1 number of times that
condition executed, whereas the
body executed N times.
Yeah, but yeah, don't worry too
much about it.
That is what I'm again and again
trying to tell you will learn in
a couple of slides that it is
not, you know, important that
one line 1 + 1 -, 1, all that
will get removed.
Yeah, don't worry about that.
But so far so good and the right
way to do that is to actually
trace the program.
Take some value of N and try to
count it like how it did.
Now, yeah, try to count it and
see how many times it executes.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you?
Yes.
No, maybe.
I plus PLUS would be return as I
equal to I + 1.
That's right.
Yeah, you have to expand it and
right treat it as two lines.
One is my addition, one is
assignment.
OK, let's talk about this
running time.
Yeah, let's take some real time
situation. Yeah.
So you're going to a library?
Yeah, you have some book already
in mind and you want that in the
library you're stepping into the
library the moment you step in.
The first table has the book
that you were thinking.
Did you do any hard work there?
Yeah.
The moment you return, you saw
the book you directly took it in
your hand.
To the best case, that was the
best thing that had to happen
that day, and it happened for
you.
That is 1 case.
The second case is you go to the
library, you start looking for
the book, you start searching
every rack you search for like 5
to 6 hours.
The whole library you have
searched then you realize that
book is not even there in the
library.
Yeah, this is the worst case
that could happen, and that is
what happened.
Meaning you did all the hard
work, but they did not give you
any benefit.
Yeah.
Is that correct?
That is the worst case, right?
And then there is it average
case where the book is lying
somewhere.
You do some hardware, then you
try to find that book somewhere
in the middle.
Yeah.
Similarly for any problem there
are these three cases.
One is an average case, one is
the best case, one is the first
case, right?
So which is the?
One that we want to analyze.
What is your take on it?
Right.
For example, in some inputs this
program is having best case like
only in you know two
milliseconds it completed worst
case it is completing and five
millisecond not more than that.
In some average cases it is
taking 4 millisecond and so on.
Now some people are telling
words.
Some people are telling were,
you know, have and so on.
So let me know.
Try to give you some pointers
there.
Yeah, Sakshi is going to prepare
for a marathon.
Yeah, she's going to participate
in upcoming, you know, marathon
race in the company.
She's preparing for it.
What she does is when all of us
are practicing in the ground,
she goes to a hill.
She's practicing in an uphill in
the uphill if she is performing
OK then will she do good in the
ground?
Yeah.
What is your take on it?
Yeah.
If she's preparing herself in
the worst case, even in a hill,
if she's practicing in the
normal ground, definitely she'll
do it.
If you are preparing for my
question paper, then everyone's
else paper is easy.
Meaning, if you prepare for the
worst, then everything else is
better.
Or maybe even better, I'll give
you, you know, real life
example, yeah.
In your best day you are sweet.
Do you agree to that?
You're you're having a good day.
All of you are very happy.
Not in your best day.
You are all previously happy.
Yeah, in your worst days, when I
want to know about your true
nature.
Yeah, maybe your siblings,
parents, spouse, they will know
about that right in your worst
today.
How are you behaving?
Yeah, in your worst today.
Also, if you are OK, you are
not, you know, out of your
control, you're doing good.
You're not?
No.
Then I will treat it as good.
Same with the case of
algorithms.
I don't want to know his best.
Today I want to know his worst
today in the worst possible
input.
When I give input N which is as
equivalent to almost Infinity,
right when I'm giving a very,
very large input, when I'm
giving all worst things possible
to him.
In that case, how is he behaving
in that only I will compare the
algorithms, meaning I will
compare two people on their
worst days, not on their best
today in best day anyway, all of
them are going to be good.
Yeah.
Is it making sense, guys?
Yeah, I mean just cooking this
up or is it seeming, you know,
making sense, right?
And algorithm may run faster on
certain datasets than on others.
Average case is often difficult
to determine.
You may tell average case is
good.
Why not go with average?
Because average is difficult to
calculate, average depends on a
lot of use cases.
It involves some probabilistic
modeling and so on.
So we will not go.
So our best bet is actually to
go with worst case in the worst
day.
How are these guys performing
right and performing well in
worst case simply means they
will perform good in the normal
input also right?
So let's take some examples.
And uh, it will be even more
clear.
Yeah, there is the small
algorithm that is doing
something.
It is going to take two
variables A&B.
It is going to add it. Yeah.
What is the time taken for this?
The same.
You know you have written a
pseudo code.
Now you'll do your primitive
operation.
What are you going to do?
Very careful guys.
This line, what does it have?
Yeah, A+B is addition and then
returning.
That's alright.
How come three Gopi only two are
here now.
Audition is 1 primitive
operation.
Returning is another primitive
operation brackets, header and
all is not counted, so only two
right no method calling and all
is not cool method calling.
I have not called here.
No.
Where have we called that?
This is just a function
definition.
I have not called it anywhere
with some number like this.
I have not done that.
Correct only about this.
We are talking and it is 2 and
this is called a constant time
taking algorithm which is our
favorite way.
Why is this our favorite?
Yeah, a lot of students don't
understand this.
Try to make sense out of this is
very important.
This is a constant time taking
algorithm, meaning regardless of
my A, this is regardless of my
B, this will always take only
two time units.
Do you agree my A's value 10 B's
value 100 Homer to the time
complexity?
How many units of time will it
take?
That unit is fine.
It is microsecond millisecond.
We are not bothered.
Time units 2 units now my A
oops, my is a very big number
like this.
And my bee is also a big number
like this.
Still, what is the complexity?
Yeah, still it is 2 because this
partition algorithm is constant
time taking.
Adding this one, returning this
one.
That's all.
Such algorithms are very good
because irrespective of your
input, you're always going to
take the same time units,
whereas if you have some other,
something like a list of
numbers.
If you want to Add all the
numbers in a list, yeah, then
that is going to take a function
of some constant meaning.
Say if you have N is equal to
500 elements and N is equal to
5000 elements or 50,000
elements, then it is going to
change.
It is not a constant right,
because here I'm adding 5000
elements whereas here I'm adding
50,000 elements, so it is
changing.
So what is the complexity in
this case?
It is proportional to these
input size right?
Some of size right.
The first one, what we saw was
constant, the previous slide sum
of the list is going to be some
constant times North, right?
That N is the size of the input.
Similarly, if you have a matrix,
if you want to sum 2 matrices,
then it is going to go even
beyond which is called North
Square and so on.
Yeah, you will learn about it.
You know later as well.
Yeah.
So initially for that sum of two
variables, it is always a
constant, right?
Let me just erase this.
Oops.
Yeah.
So whatever input I take you in,
my complexity is remaining the
same no problem.
But whereas for a list, if I
want to submit a list as my N is
growing, this is slowly growing,
it is going to take more time.
Here this is time right?
Similarly for North squared it
is going even beyond just for
two matrices I'm going to take
this much time.
We want to add five matrices.
It'll go somewhere here, right?
It's even larger, right?
So which one is good for us?
Which time complexity is very
good for us out of, say,
constant yen N square in cube
and so on.
Constant is very good because
regardless of the input it'll
go.
It'll be working in the same and
now there are two rules.
Yeah, we'll just finish these
rules and pass for today.
Yeah, these rules tells we
analyze time complexity on a
very large input size.
What did we discuss?
Whenever we are analyzing
algorithms, which case are we
going to analyze?
Is it best case or average case
or worst case?
Yeah, which case are we going to
1st case?
So we are already telling that
we are going to use worst case
and imagine your input size to
be very large N large in meaning
it is as good as Infinity.
Such a large N.
OK, so if you see this term, how
you would have got this line,
can someone take a guess the of
N is equal to N Q3 N square some
line you have written how you
got this line?
You had got a similar line
today.
Yeah, 610 plus you remember
that.
So you have returned some
programs sudo code.
You have countered it.
You have submitted it and
finally you have got that answer
and then this use case you have
got such an answer and got it
right all of you taking all of
you you analyzed you wrote a
code.
You analyzed it using counter
primitive in the RAM model you
submitted it, you got an answer
like this.
In that answer, you're going to
do 2 things.
One is when this end is going to
be very, very large.
This end cube term will be very
dominant.
It will be a very big number in
that is this tool even going to
matter?
Is this four and all this going
to matter?
So what you will do is you will
drop the lower order terms, you
will drop all these terms.
You'll ignore it, right?
And then there is a second rule.
Which days drop the constant
multiplier meaning?
For example, if you see this
first line, 17 N power four when
north is very very very large,
these 3 N cubed is 8 four and
all doesn't matter.
This will be small values, but
this will be a very big value,
so ignore these terms.
What you get is 17 empower 4 in
that 17 empower 4.
The second rule says this N
power four is the dominating
guy.
What does the 17?
It's a constant, so cancel him
also.
So what remains is your time
complexity.
Yeah, let's do that for a couple
of problems.
Four N + 5 who is the dominant
term?
Yeah, 4 N right?
So if I use smaller so eliminate
him, 4 N remains right out of
this point by end log N minus 2
N plus 7 N log N is the, you
know dominant term, so it cancel
these out of two power N cubed,
three power N 2 power N is
dominant, cancel the lower order
term.
Similarly, eliminate the
constant coefficient.
Meaning, if you have four and
four is a constant, so eliminate
him.
Also, N remains in point when
login.
Eliminate the .5 N log N
remains.
That is why I was telling you,
when you get answers like 6 N
plus one or six N minus two and
so on, it doesn't matter because
anyway you will delete this.
Delete this.
This will be N here also delete
this delete.
This will be so that small plus
1 -, 1, it doesn't matter in the
big picture, when you have a
very large right.
So what you get finally after
this, meaning you wrote the
pseudo code you analyzed it, you
counted the primitives you
submitted it.
You applied these two rules,
which is called eliminating the
lower order and eliminating the
constant.
And finally you will get some
answer.
Yeah.
Will you get to some answer?
Yes.
No.
Do you mean the constant would
make huge difference though.
No it will not, because I'm
imagining this end to be almost
equal to Infinity when this is
such a big Infinity.
Then why is that constant going
to matter, right?
Doesn't matter in two power N it
depends on the value of N,
right?
That is why always we are
imagining in is as large as
Infinity.
We are.
We are not talking about small
lengths, right?
So finally you will get one
answer.
Yeah.
And from that answer, we will
start our class next class, we
will look at what is that
answer, how is it going to help
us and so on, right.
That answer that we get is
called as order of growth and
whatever program you analyze.
Finally, you are going to get an
answer like this, right?
We will talk about this.
We will talk about this order of
growth and finally that answer
you will put it inside something
called as a notation.
You look at that also in the
next class, it kind of making a
common ground to compare with
large values exactly right
because we are going to have a
worst case.
Yeah, it is the same thing,
Vinay.
Yeah.
So Professor Raghavan would have
covered these topics in his
class.
Now how 17 the small number?
Uh, in ¥17 power four put a
number for it is not N power
four.
Yeah.
Who decided that?
Four.
Yeah.
We are always imagining a very
large N, right?
So in that case the small
constants doesn't matter out of
17 and out of you know, your yen
power four.
If you imagine this yen to be a
very, very large number, that
answer is way, way greater than
this 17, right?
So it is not needed.
Simple rule, always eliminate
the constant coefficient.
Yeah, simple stuff.
Yeah, I will just.
It is all this and if you just
you know you can ignore this
slide, we will come back to
these three slides later.
But there is some questions.
This slide is important.
Yeah.
The first three questions you
will be able to answer write a
pseudo code for the below and
count the primitives.
Have you already learned this?
Yeah.
Do you know how to write a
pseudo code and how to count the
primitive and submit it and
eliminate those two constant and
you know constant coefficient
and load order term for all
these type of programs you will
do it and you will put it in our
discussion forum.
Yeah.
The other topic of order of
growth and the symbols and all
that we will start in the next
class and try to do that.
Yeah, I'll quickly stop the
recording and we will meet the
next Saturday.